welcome to kids taste testing gourmet  food today's meal begins with a delicacy  so divine that its name has come to mean  the best in its class  caviar these salt cured fish eggs are  extremely difficult to procure in large  quantities and can sell for up to $300  per ounce it's like I still know what it  is our next course on today's menu is  squid ink pasta a dish known for its  distinct briny flavor this particular  pasta was made with ink imported from  Italy widely considered to be the best  money can buy herbs like worms  I like it  it's pretty good but it looks bad those  are classic rules nothing says I'm  wealthy like having so much gold you are  literally eating it since at least the  16th century eating gold has been a  tradition amongst the wealthy in both  Europe and Japan it is usually served as  either flakes or a dust we decided to  try both I like it it tastes like keeper  look suffered thank everything you have  let second charlie